we do in the morning in the evening time
[Music]
Little Caesars you know they got a soft
spot in my heart because they got me
through college I definitely have always
hated Domino's yeah I mean if it's there
I'm gonna eat it breathe up Gracie
perfect that's the most important thing
is if you can hold it out fanzone sounds
I got some good sauce on here
the crust is pretty like ready I know
this tweet I feel like I think this is
Little Caesars
I think it's r2 you know I can tell at
the bottom of it that's like the pizza
you get in elementary school I'm gonna
like passed out after this I can just
tell you that right now this is like a
good slice is a heavy slice he's like
hella cheesy this pizza does not have
enough sauce they went out of their way
to kind of throw some more spices in
here I think this is better this one's
like poor Elana lunchable and this one
is like oh man there was some love put
into this there were three looks like
[ __ ] is what this is like people you
would get in an airport it's a little
too bougie like they're trying to make
it a little too fancy for me all right
next one is hands-down the poorest
looking things at this pizza I am NOT
haha smells like a play place I've got
like a ditch before the crust where like
the soft hand really collects and it's
way too intense top crust not bad Papa
John's is always lack on the crust like
that crust is get in my mouth
I only you know what I know this is
pizza hot body crust
yeah exactly good cause this is good a
little fluffy that's kind of tastes like
bread you get before your meal and some
restaurant but this would like cheese
and pepperoni sauce it just tastes like
butter like butter bread with cheese on
top and I'm all about that I think I
think this one is the boss 100% this one
is my favorite and I know
that'd be good I think this one was my
favorite
I thought this was the best too but I
still think it's Papa John's so nice
what we think is demise that is my
favorite it is so good Domino's you
stepped up your game one two three yes
dominoes dominoes really killing I had
damn Domino's I noticed the cheese
lighter on the sauce but I notice it
that garlic seasoning
[Music]